congress appears to be close to passing
a 900 billion dollar
relief package amidst the kobit 19
pandemic
now part of that package would include a
payment of 600
for most of us that could happen as
unemployment benefits run
out for more than 10 million americans
at the end of this year today we asked
congresswoman susie lee if this deal
goes far
enough i don't think this package is
enough at all
i mean first of all remember you know
our own
federal reserve chairman back in may
said that we needed to go
big um and we started out with the three
trillion dollar package it went to two
trillion and now we're less than a
trillion
i believe we will come back to the uh we
will come back with another package in
the next congress
uh and so i think this is obviously a
stop
gap measure it's something to get relief
to people who especially in southern
nevada so many of our families
have been struggling and businesses are
on the
verge of collapse and so this couldn't
come at a more critical time
congresswoman lee is hopeful the next
package includes more aid for
local governments who are facing a
crunch as well she also tells eight news
now that this deal would include a plan
to
distribute the covid19 vaccines